at the end of a storm of swords end of
season 4 of Game of Thrones Tywin
Lannister is killed by his son Tyrion
but a popular theory claims that Tywin
is already dying that he's poisoned by
Oberyn Martell so Oberyn Martell is the
younger brother of Doran Martell the
Prince of Dorne and of Elia Martell who
was murdered in Robert's rebellion Oh
burns the father of eight bastard
daughters called the sand snakes who he
had with various women including al
arias and Oberyn has a fearsome
reputation as a fighter and a lover he's
traveled the Free Cities studied at the
Citadel and soldiered in the disputed
lands Doran calls him deadly dangerous
unpredictable Tywin calls him half mad
Varys says he's a proud man and
sentimental Oberyn was close with his
sister Elia and like the rest of his
family he's outraged by her murder at
the hands of Gregor Clegane so when he
comes to King's Landing Oberyn makes
clear that he comes for justice not just
for Gregor but for the man who gave his
orders Tywin he never says outright that
he wants to kill Tywin but he hints it
heavily to Tyrion telling him your
father may not live forever oberyn's
known as a poisoner having learned the
trade on his travels in his fight with
Gregor Clegane Oberyn uses a poisoned
spear which is what kills Gregor after
Auburn's own death
he's also rumoured to have used a
poisoned sword in a duel with Lord Edgar
Ironwood back when Oberyn was 16
disowned him the name red Viper so we
know over and wants revenge on Tywin and
we know Oberyn uses poisons is there
evidence that Tywin is poisoned before
he's killed by Tyrion on the night of
Tywin's death Tyrion finds his father in
the Privy which some fans suggest shows
that Thailand's been poisoned with
widows blood a poison mentioned by
pycelle that shuts down a man's bladder
and bowels until he drowns in his own
poisons but being on the toilet doesn't
prove that you've been given
constipation poison right especially
considering she is in Tywin's bed at the
time are we meant to believe Tywin was
in the mood while his bowels were shut
down and he was drowning in his own
poisons others point to the line saying
that Tyrion finds his father where he
knew he'd find him seated in the tomb
of the briefie tower but Tyrion knows
Tywin is there not because he knows his
own widows blood but because Tyrion was
just in Tywin's bedroom where he
expected to fight him and Tywin wasn't
there
so Tywin being in the Privy is not
evidence that his poisoned but there is
another thing after Tywin's death
something weird and gross and wrong goes
on with his corpse which is laid out in
the Sept of Baelor the body rots with
greenish skin and leaking fluid and it
stinks so badly that Tommen wretches PI
cells eyes water and one of the most
devout has to be helped from the room
Davos hears that the corpse stinks so
badly that no one is able to enter the
Sept for days afterward this isn't meant
to happen
the room is filled with incense and
silent sisters prepare the body removing
bowels and organs stuffing insults and
fragrant herbs yet times body still
really stinks what does this mean
there's a famous Russian book called The
Brothers Karamazov where a monk dies and
his body stinks afterwards shocking and
upsetting people and making them think
that the monk was somehow corrupt or
dishonest so in the same way the stink
of Thailand's corpse might mean his a
rotten person it might mean that his
murder by his son is terrible and wrong
that he is relationships with his family
and his legacy are bad and tywin's
rotting smiling corpse is a mockery of
his pride and power and sternness in
life so the horror of Thailand's body
means lots of things some have suggested
that it also shows that Thailand's body
is corrupted by poison but this doesn't
actually make a whole lot of sense if
Tywin is poisoned by a groan it must
happen before oberyn's death in Tyrion
10 the most likely time seems Jaime 7
when Tywin has breakfast with Oberyn but
whenever it happens there's a good chunk
of time between the poisoning and
Thailand's death so it seems really
weird that Tywin is apparently totally
unaffected by the poison right up until
he's dead when it suddenly makes his
body gross it is plausible that Oberyn
could use some slow-acting poison but
it's pretty implausible that the poison
would only happen to kick in right after
time and death and it's only affects our
decomposition and ickiness that can
happen naturally anyway so especially
considering that the horror of
Thailand's corpse already means a bunch
of stuff it doesn't seem to
have anything to do with poison one
other thing to consider during oberyn's
brother says he's been working at the
downfall of Tywin Lannister since
Robert's rebellion hoping to strip Tywin
of all that he holds most dear before
killing him so he's disappointed when
Tyrion kills Tywin Doran doesn't want
thailand dead yet this is important
because Doran says that he works closely
with Oberyn in their plans to strike at
their enemies if they're working closely
together
Oberyn would surely share dorans goal of
stripping time when of all the holds
most dear before killing him so he
wouldn't kill him right after arriving
at King's Landing it's true that
overruns impatient unpredictable
bloodthirsty even but would a
bloodthirsty man secretly an enormous
Lee kill his enemy with a slow-acting
poison
look at how Oberyn kills Gregor he makes
a show of it demands a public confession
insists on killing Gregor with his own
hands it's not at all overrun style to
quietly poison Tywin and it probably
goes against Doran and oberyn's plans
so at first glance it seems totally
reasonable to think that Oberon might
poison Tywin Oberyn wants revenge on
Tywin overruns known to use poison the
two even have a convenient breakfast
together not long before Tywin's death
but the closer you look at this theory
the less sense it makes oberyn's known
to use poisoned weapons and jewels but
slipping poison into people's morning
tea is not his style at all slow-acting
poison too which apparently has no
effect on Tywin in the time between
oberyn's death and his timings being on
the Privy and the stench of his corpse
have more to do with subverting his
dignity and reputation than with any
exotic poison at the end of the day
while it is possible that over in
poisons Tywin there's no evidence that
it happens and there are good reasons to
believe that it probably doesn't so the
most reasonable conclusion is that
Oberyn did not poison Tywin thanks for
watching
you